Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier..
and welcome back to 'I Am Bread.'
Now, 'I Am Bread' is some what infamous on my channel.
It's one of the shortest series I've ever done,
IF you can even call it a series,
with the most recent episode
of the World's Quietest Let's Play,
as a reintroduction to this
HORRIFYINGLY
horrible game, to you guys.
And in the short
2, pretty much just
2 episodes that I did of this
about 2 years ago,
[takes breath] I've never felt
more rage or hatred
for any other game, in my entire,
life.
But I'd like to think that I've
matured over the years
and I'd like to think that I can approach this with some new perspective
and I believe that MAYBE I can beat this game.
But, I wanna warn you guys
I literally hate this game.
[Begins to chuckle slightly] I legitimately, literally hate this game,
I literally HATE IT
But I wanna FACE it,
Because I wanna CONQUER IT,
Because I WANNA BURY IT IN THE GROUND
AND LIVE MY LIFE FREE..!
...of People Demanding that I play it, So..
[Sigh]
Lets begin, shall we?
Oh, no..
Oh, I already hate it...
How..
How!
H-h-howw??
Howwwww?????
Alright, lets not lose faith just yet.
Let's do..
Eugh..
[Inhales sharply]
[Exhales deeply] OK. Alright
Easy peasy!
So I can only assume.. that I need to LEAP...
[Grunts]
If I jump..
if I just
[Grunts]
EURGHHH!
Okay, got that.
Grip is... dying but, I seem to be doing - No-that-no-no-nOOO NO0OoOo0OooO0o
Just drop down there and grab-
GRAB! GRAB!
Just fucking-! Okay
you son of a.. just..
Oh my God.
UH!
[Exhales]
Oh, my God..
Oh m- [Growls]
[Sighs]
Lets just..
Flip... and then, flip
Ooooh. Not quite
There we go!
And then let's just.. Oh..
Ah!
You can grab, thank y-
[Cup smashes]
[Inhales]
AHRGRGR
[Groans softly]
[Growls] RAHHH!
WHAT DID YOU DO?!
NOOOOOOOOO
Don't give me that gar-
I have had TWO times
Death-ness..?
That's not words but FUCK you
How about those words?
Don't insult me with that bullshit
I'm not gonna use your magic pills.
Oh, boy.. we're coming back-
OOoohhh
How do I get out of this gulloooooOOOO
Kay.
That's good.
Alright,
so where... is the ohh.. the radiator!
Okay
So I don't care how much time I take
All that matters TO ME is that I get to the end.
That's literally all I care about
so.
How hard could it be?
Yo i'm just gonna.. I'm just gonna nudge
I'm not gonna try to grab onto nothing
I'm not gonna-- oh is there-? Oh, there's fingernail clippings over there
UEWWWWW
I'm trying to make him, I'm gonna try to make him maneuver here.
If I can.
It wont let me.
AHHHH NO WHOA AH LET GO OH MY GOD WHAT DO I DO?
[Calmly] Nailed it
Why's the grip so bad now? Why is the grip so bad NOW?
OooOooho aHAh-aAh
Don't ew.. DON'T! DON'T! STOP
STOP STOP STOP
uh
Uhnn
Okay, fuckin'..
OOOOHOHOHOHO
Riggghht there, right there, righ right there
Okay
AAHHH
AHHH
UUHH
ah fuck you..
..oh my god..
(deep breathing)
aAHH
WHY WHY WHY WHAT ARE YOU DOING WHY ARE YOU DOING IT WHAT ARE YOU DOING DO NOT LET GO OH MY GOD WHAT THE FUCK
what are you doing
STOOOOOOOOOOP
OOOH MY GOODDD
uUUUUUHHHHH
UUUUUUUUUUUUUUUHH
rrsjHjsZBHOSZHO
K, good, clear, right-
Yes
How do I get these things out of my way?
Can I just push them off?
Can I just push them, can I push them off?
Can I just puuush
Can I just pusH THEM OFF
I just push them
Gonne nudge
all I'm gonna do
gonna clap slap ya
HUP
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
AH AHHH
UHH UHH
UHH UHH UHH
UHHHNN
Pppfpfpfpfpfhhhhhh
All we have to do
is not getting in the toilet
OH MY GOD MARK, YOU DID IT, GIVE YOURSELF A PAT ON THE BACK
I did it
Ok
Can I make that jump
I think I can
OOOHHH
hhhwwooowoww
OOOOOHHHHH
I'M GETTING IT
I'M GETTING IT GUYS
oH
Theres Jam there
I don't wanna go for the bonus Jam
I've been jammed, is that good or bad?
but now theres shards of glass everywhere
and that's not what I wanted
OW WHY WHY WHAT AM I TOUCHING WHAT AM I TOUCHING THATS BAD
What was I touching that was bad
Frankly, i'm gonna stay away from it and go the otherway because you're being a son of a b1tch
GGRGRGFFF
HAWHAWHAWHAW HOOHOHOHH
If I just don't get in the water i'll be okay right?
its so tantalizingly close
Ooohohoh i'm so close
Oh god
Ok
I need to think about this very calmly
OH OH OH
WHOA OH
OH OH
OOOH WHAAAYYY
UHN
Gotta move fast
Just
that one then right trigger oh
Oh
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO(it was this moment where Mark knew he fucked up lol)
OH OH OH
NOOOOOOOOOO
*Mark screaming in pain*
jUST if I had gotten there I would've been on my way
it Would've been practically easy
WHOUP AHHH
NOOO
NOT WHAT I WANTED
Get up, Oh Oh yeah
That's how, How did you
Make that manuever
if I knew how you made that Manuever
WHOAAAHH
Ho Hawww AHHHH
WHYY
WHY?
WHY JUST
How are you not bragging on it, ok
I'm about to lose my grip so I gotta - I'm about to lose my mind
Hoooo There we go
HEEYYYYYY
WE DID IT
Heyy.
How about that
we're a little gross, but
Ryan God here we go can't move forward
boy got it nailed it yoiyyoo that
worked out pretty well
surprisingly no that's not correct
there there no that's also no that's not
don't you fucking dare you piece of shit
you know JUST whyyyy WHY you I don't understand you
why all right just fucking nudge him off don'ṭ̣̣̣̣̣̣̣
don't hump the bottle beautiful
butterflies oh ah cartwheeling into
death if now what I want to do today
okay push all that shit off push it off
push it right off right the f off can
you just please why would you do physics
like that why you know I don't like you
and you don't like me but maybe we could
just agree to disagree and then you go
fuck yourself that's a good arrangement
easy
back here again easy I'm getting better
at this which is not something I'm happy
to say but I am oddly enough getting
better at this Oh beautiful
yeah okay all right oh fuck me oh my god
that's oh that's that's that's fun
that's that's fun that's fun of that to
happen that way yeah there we go oh okay
all right well we're standing bread now
okay okay okay okay
all right okay I think I just got to
jump and get on that radiator I think Oh
what what what what what why am I not
toasting well I'm sizzling business in
no toasts why please explain to me why
no toasts
I hear sizzles and no toast I see a
bright red light down there I don't know
what it's all about but I don't know if
has anything to do with what we were
doing up here it's oh hey okay bumpers
only I can't reach it
I can't I just I fucking can't I fucking
can't
oh god why what in the fuck no don't
fuck me like this
what are you doin oh my god oh my god I'm
again now oh please please stay here oh
my god what I what is that it's a power
cord uh-huh get up there they get up
there and get up there and then do it
huh I don't know why the cameras being
all fucking like that but I don't like
it how do I
Oh No now milk no get up Obama hit
something what are you doing
oh no no why Cameron oh not now no no no
no no please please just get out there
please I'm right there please just let
the fucking thing why are you toastin
there just get up Oh what the fuck now
are we're toasting hey wait no no get
turned over like that
you know what I did it I did it and I
was learning and I was trying to
approach it rationally and I think we
can all say that wasn't that bad so I
think I can do more of that I think I
honestly think I can so let me know if
you guys want to see more down in the
comments below I could do them after a
long break in a few days rest I could
probably do another one of those but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down below and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye